how's it going guys matt here code tech
materials just going to update the i am
gui uh
repo and just add a second video just
based on some of the comments i decided
to take another look at it and see if
there was anything i missed it looks
like it could use some updating so just
to clarify a few things
this is pulling down the libraries with
vc pkg and if you're not if you don't
have that set up you'll have to do the
libraries a different way but i'd
recommend just using vc pkg i do have a
video on that but also i'll just link
the documentation on it because it's
kind of faster to go through the
documentation than watch my video but if
you're still stuck on it just watch the
video
and we're using cmake in this particular
one there's a top level cmake of course
and one that says use subdirectory so it
goes to this one sets up all the
libraries makes the executable
so when cmake runs it should do all this
stuff it should grab these libraries if
you have vc pkg set up
and it should make your executable when
you build it now it's going to make the
executable based off your config and we
have a few configs set up
already in the cmake json basically a
debug and a release so when you go to
run it you have to click up here and go
to uh a target and we've got a target
ready to go right there so if you hit
play it should run now i made a few
changes
to just a few other things which i'm
going to go ahead and show and that is
the code i noticed this code was a
little lackluster sure okay let's look
at this base class and use i am gui
we've got net new frame update render
shutdown update is virtual so you can
over load it or overwrite it if you want
but uh
it has a base version and i was looking
at this and it was a little weird and
maybe not quite right so there's this
render conan logo now this is a local
function a function that's only
available in this cpp unless we x turn
it into our other one which we're not
going to do but if you want to use in
your main one you can of course just go
x turn boom and then you can use it in
here if you want but
if we look at it
it doesn't have an im gui begin and it
doesn't have an end so in the update
uh the one that's in the non-overwritten
version so if you don't override it it's
going to just do this one
we have a begin it says hello world i'm
going to put
conan logo instead
and just update this and then it's going
to call this render cone and logo and
then end so you gotta have a beginning
and an end of course and this is all the
stuff middle so there's a nice little
example there and everything else the
render and shutdowns all the same for
glfw and opengl but now let's look at
our example we made our own custom class
inherited from use iron gui and we over
ride the update so this is going to be
called instead if we use our own custom
gui and we've just got some some basic
kind of random stuff in here and i
changed the begin to custom gui hello
world that way you can tell it's coming
from but this is going to get called
normally so we go down to our main you
know it's got the setup and all that
stuff and eventually
uh we get to the while loop and that's
where all the stuff happens we got a new
frame update render now this update is
what's going to call this one here but
if we comment this out
it should change to the logo there's the
conan logo
and then if we overwrite it we should
get what we actually put in there so
let's go ahead and do that and let's
make sure it builds
yeah there we go
and there's
our code so there's a you know there's a
lot we could do here we the clear color
is not actually updated so what's
supposed to happen
is uh we should be using this to change
gl so let's just make another function
here called void uh update
or change clear color
all right we'll make this one private
change clear color and it's just going
to use
opengl stuff to clear the color and now
we need to take this static float and
let's actually make it a member here of
our class so let's just make it a
private member
we bring it in here by reference so that
should work fine
and uh yeah we won't mess with the rest
of it but let's actually make this clear
color change our background color and
the way we do that is well we call this
gl clear color right here
so we're going to take that out of there
and put it right here and now we just
need to decide when to call this
function so this thing if we look at
these color edits they do return a
boolean
so you can see it there on the hover it
might be a little small but if you go
look at the imgui code for color edit it
returns a boolean
for when it changes so
we're gonna just put like
clear we're gonna make a local clear
color change and then after this end we
can just say if clear color changed
all
change clear color
and that should be enough i guess i'll
put it in brackets just to make it super
clear but this little local variable
should be true if it changed and call
this function so i had this variable
accidentally named the function name
that of course would throw an error as
expected
all right so there we go and now it's
set to some random value but as we
change it it should actually update our
background a little better
let's give it some defaults though so
let's just use an initializer list here
and we'll just go let's just default it
to zero because we're gonna call this at
least once otherwise it's just gonna be
the default color that
initializes as which is this black color
so there we go now we can change it just
like so
and that's a little better a little more
interactive
and we could do more stuff if we want
but i think that's fine for now let's
make sure these are floats and i'm going
to go ahead and push these little
updates
maybe you're using vs code and that's
actually fine so let's do an example
with visual studio code well i'm just
going to open the cmake with visual
studio code here like so but essentially
if you're using visual studio code and
you've got the default cmake
application it should
detect most of your stuff and it's going
to pop up and ask you what compiler you
want to use and that's fine i've added
the get ignore for the build directory
that vs code makes and the imgui any
that you're going to get
and this vs code is going to by default
build it into the build folder whereas
visual studio goes into help build etc
so a little different there but to do
this one well i i'm gonna upload this
file but basically it's gonna put your
runtime into this directory so for vs
code you need that little launch.json to
make this debug button work but first
you have to build it and to build it you
got to go into terminal and
you basically need to go into your build
and then to imgui
and look for this project
and that you need to call ms build on it
or whatever compiler you're using bubble
i am gui
dot vc project okay so that should
actually build it and we got some you
know some double to flow warnings but
we're not going to worry about those but
actually built serial errors so then it
should
have the program you can look at that
manually and you can path to it and
launch it in your command line
uh just like let's see where is it
it's in debugs we're building as debug
and then uh there it is there's an
executable so you can just like dot
slash i'm gui uh
sample let's see if this works yep there
we go so you can do it this way too
essentially about the same or if you
have this launch.json setup this path
you can just hit this play button once
you have it built and boom there you go
all right so i'm going to push these
changes i made let me know if you have
any further questions or problems but
hopefully that helps you get going check
out cmake
episode 10 on my channel if you're still
confused about how to use cmake over
here on visual studio code and the whole
ms build thing so i do cover that a
little more in depth in that video
alright thanks for watching peace out
guys
you